[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استاهلوها بابرز
العلوم
المنتخب المغربي تصدر مجموعه هو يتاهل
للدوري السته عشر متفوقا على كرواتيا
وبلجيكا وكندا
اتفاق مبدايا اوروبيه على تحديد سقف السعر
النفط الروسي المنقول بحرا بستين دولار
للبرميل
طالب وتركيا باعاده تقييم خططها شمال
سوريا وانقر ترد وتطالبها بوقف تصليح
الاكراد
[موسيقى]
بتهمه الاعتداء على امن الدوله مذكره من
القضاء التونسي لضبط واحضار نجد الغنوشي
[موسيقى]
حقق المنتخب المغربي انجازا تاريخيا اخر
يسجل باسمه واسم العرب بعد تاهله متصدر
مجموعته السادسه في كاس العالم في قطر عقب
فوزه على المنتخب الكندي بهدفين مقابل هدف
واحد ووصل رصيد المنتخب المغربي الى سبع
نقاط متفوقا على كرواتيا التي جمعت خمس
نقاط وبلجيكا باربعه نقاط بينما جاء
المنتخب الكندي في المركز الاخير بثلاثه
وتعتبر هذه المره الثانيه بعد مونديال عام
1986 الذي يتاهل فيه المغرب متصدرا
مجموعته كاول منتخب عربي وينتظر المنتخب
المغربي الذي بات اول منتخب عربي يتصدر
المجموعه بكاس العالم ينتظر وصيف المجموعه
الخامسه في الدور السادس عشر
مزيد من الاخبار مشاهدينا مع زميل عبد
الله اليك عبد الله
[موسيقى]
عن تاهل المنتخب المغربي التاريخي ينضم
الينا من مكان الحدث العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه الزميل فهد الشهري وايضا ينضم
الينا من العاصمه المغربيه الرباط الزميل
محمود بومباري يبدا معك اولا فهد من
الدوحه فهد نقول ان الاجواء لديه كيف هي
نعم نحن لازلنا هنا مع الجمهور المغربي في
استاد التاريخ في استاد اعاده تاريخ في
استاد الثمامه بالدوحه حيث يكرر المنتخب
المغربي انجاز 86 ويتاهل متصدرا امام
منتخبين اوروبيين كبيرين كرواتيا وبلجيكا
المنتخب المغربي تصدر هذه المجموعه بكل
جداره عبد الله كسره كل الارقام من كان
يقول انها انتصار المنتخب المغربي امام
بلجيكا صدفه هو يكمل الافاه ويلجم جميع
مشاكل في منتهى المنتخب المغربي بفوز
واستحقاق وسيطره
ومنع المنتخب الكندي من الاحداث اي مفاجاه
اليوم منتخب المغربي اكد على استحقاقه
ويقول لكل المغربيين ولكل العرب مبروكين
مبروكين مبروكين للجميع مبروك للجميع
المنتخب المغربي اليوم مع جمهور الكبير
عبد الله كان في جمهور كبير لم يستطع ايضا
دخول الملعب كانت الاح طلعت ولا زالت هنا
جزء من عندك الجموع الكبيره
[موسيقى]
طيب فهد ساعتها جاء الى الرباط محمود
محمود كيف هي الاجواء في المغرب
الوصول الى دور السته عشر المنتخب يتصدر
هذه المجموعه بجداره بهدفين في مرمى كندا
فوز على بلجيكا تعادل مع وسيط بطل العالم
انقرض الاجواء محمود
طبعا اليوم هي امطار الخير التي كانت
الفال الاكبر لانتصار المنتخب المغربي
وعبره للدوره الثانيه اعاده سيناريو
مونديال 86 اليوم سبع نقاط غاليه كاول
منتخب مغربي عربي يحققه هذه الميقات متصدر
لمجموعه كما اسلفت فيها منتخب كرواتيا
وفيها منتخب بلجيكا الثاني عالميا خاصه
طبعا الثقه همم تصاعد من سوبر ثقه بعد
الفوز على على بلجيكا اليوم كان الشارع
ينتظر تاكيد الفوز في ملعب الثوم الذي هو
تميمه حظ للمنتخب المغربي الذي يقوده لاول
مره مدرب مغربي يعبر الى الدور الثاني بعد
بعد المدرب مهدي فاريا في مونديال 86
اليوم رغم بروده الطقس لكن هذه الجماهير
احاله المكان والاماكن الى اماكن دافئه
الى اماكن تعبر عن الحماس تعبر عن
الاعتزاز بهذا المنتخب الشاب الذي استطاع
ان يعيد هذه القصه التي انتظرها ال- ال-
ال- ال- المغاربه ينتظرها يعني انتظرها
كذلك العرب اليوم سبع نقاط خالده سطر اخر
من تاريخ كره القدم المغربيه يكتب في
ملاعب السومه يكتب في مونديال قطر نعم
اليوم العنوان الابرز تاهل مستحق وكبير
وعندي بعرض كبير للمنتخب المغربي محمود
مبارك
شكرا جزيلا لكما وينضم الينا هنا في
الاستديو همم اللاعب المغربي الدوري
السابق سفيان العلودي اهلا بك كابتن سفيان
يعني همم الفرحه ما هي سائعات تصدر لا
تكلمني
كيف هذا الفوز الحمد لله يعني قبل ما
نتكلم على على الفوز نحب نشكر اللاعبين
الطاقه والاتحاد الكره في المغرب اللي
قدموا دور اول من هذا البطوله واحد الشكل
الممتاز وممتاز بزاف نقدر نقول شكرا لهم
الشعب المغربي لانه كان محتاجه في الدار
الاوروبيه يعني همم
طريقه تسيير المنتخب يعني مع وليد شفنا
منتخب ثاني للمنتخب المغربي كان كان يشكى
بان المنتخب ليس منتخب فعل ولكن
اليوم همم هزيت راسنا ارفعت راسنا ولكن
ثقتنا فيكم خلتنا مازال نزيدوا نطمعوا
اكثر همم
والمانيا وحتى اليابان وكوستاريكا ولكن
يعني عطفن على التاريخ من الممكن
مستوى الاول المستوى المباراه الاولى
والمستوى المباراه الثانيه والمستوى
المباراه الثانيه بغض النظر على الشوط
الثاني
مباشره الى ليان عذريه ومزيد من اخبار
المتعلقه بالمدير تفضلي اليه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك عبد الله سانتقل الان مشاهدينا
الى الدوحه مجددا والزميل ليث بازاري ليس
كيف هي الصوره من هناك على ما يبدو انك
بعيد عن مكان المشجعين
ليال هذه الصوره غير مالوفه في المونديال
نحن في الطريق تركنا
ثمامه قبل قليل ملعب الثمامه خلفي من هذا
في عمق الصوره ومتجهون الان الى سوق واقف
الذي سيتحول سوق واقف هنا في الدوحه الذي
ستحول الى جامع الفنا في مراكش الاحتفالات
جميع الشباب او المشجعين للمنتخب المغربي
يتجهون من هذه الطريق نشاهد حافلات احيانا
اذا حافله مثلا هذه الحافله تنقل مشجعين
ينتقلون مباشره الى سوق واقف الى
الاحتفال بهذا الفوز هذا الفوز العربي هنا
في الدوحه خلال المونديال والجميع طبعا
سوف يحتفل انا متاكد حتى ساعات الصباح
الباكر كما حصل قبل ذلك واحتفالات المنتخب
السعودي همم عندما ربح الارجنتين وكما
احتمل وكم احتفل المنتخب المغربي فوزها
قبل هذه المره وهذه الاجواء ولكن نحن في
الطريق يعني فضلنا ان نكون في طريقنا الى
السوق واقف ونحتفل وننقل الصوره هناك
مباشره بدل ما نكون في الملعب الذي يتوجه
جميع مشجعينه الى سوق واقف وسط الدوحه ليس
فقط واقف ولكن هناك اماكن اخرى قطاره
اللؤلؤه الكورنيش والجميع مناطق الدوحه
يعني الوضع همم شفت شباب قبل شوي يحملون
الطبول ويحملون المزامير ويذهبون بهذا
الاتجاه
يعني حتى تصل الى هناك ونعود وننقل صوره
الاحتفالات اما بالتاسعه واما مع الزملاء
راويه وطاهر لاحقا
راح نحاول نكون بالتاسعه ان شاء الله
تشهد بطوله كاس العالم 2022 في قطر غياب
كوكب من نجوم كره القدم الحاليين والذي
كان وجودهم سيجعل بطوله اكثر متعه وايثاره
على راسي المصري محمد صلاح نجم نادي
ليفربول والجزائري رياض محرز مهاجم فريق
مانشستر سيتي وزميله المهاجم النرويجيها
لاند هؤلاء فشلت منتخباتهم في بلوغ
المونديال لكن هنالك نجوم تاهلت منتخباتهم
لكنهم غابوا اما بداعي الاصابه او
الاستبعاد
كديفيدخيه حارس منتخب اسبانيا الذي
استبعده المدرس او المدرب الوسوا امريكا
في البريميوم ليجا برفقه مانشستر يونايتد
وهناك النجم الفرنسيه
في ركبته وخضع لجراحه ابعدته عن كاس
العالم في قطر
[موسيقى]
المشاركه في نهائيات كاس العالم حلمهن
راود وما يزعل نجوم كره القدم حول العالم
لكن تشاء الظروف احيانا الى عدم تحقيق ذلك
الحلم نهائيا فهنالك اساطير لم تسمح لهم
الفرصه لتسجيل حضورهم في المونديال بينما
كانوا في اوج عطائهم الفني وفي افضل
المراحل في مشوارهم الكروي ذلك بسبب اقصاء
طبعا منتخباتهم من التاهل لنهائيات كاس
العالم ابرزهم مشاهدينا الوزير ريان
احد ابرز اللاعبين في تاريخ نادي مانشستر
يونايتد وتعثر عليه اللاعب في المونديال
اذ لم ينجح منتخب ويلز في الوصول الى
النهائيات عندما كان ريان لاعبا في صفوف
المنتخب
جائزه افضل او جائزه افضل لاعب في العام
سواء 90 كاول لاعب فريقي بعد تالقه مع
انديه ميلان الايطاليه وموناكو وباريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسيين وعجز عن المشاركه
بالمونديال بسبب ضعف مستوى منتخب بلاده
ابدا طبعا جورج همم ويا ايضا اصبح رئيسا
لللايبيريا والمفارقه يلعب ابنه اليوم في
المنتخب الامريكي وسنخصص له فقره اليوم
خلال التاسعه ايضا من اللاعبين الذين لم
يحققوا حلم المونديال
الفرنسي اليك كانت همم من افضل اللاعبين
الذين لعبوا في الدوري الانجليزيه الممتاز
بقميص مانشستر يونايتد محرز اكثر من 160
هدفا في مسيرته الكرويه وكان قريبا من
المونديال بمناسبتين في عام 1994 التي غاب
عنها المنتخب الفرنسي بعد خسارته
وفي مونديال
1998 فضل امريكا مدرب المنتخب الفرنسي
النجم زين الدين زيدان على
وهناك ايضا النجم الايرلندي جورج بس همم
صاحب الكره الذهبيه في عام
1968 واحد افضل من لعب في مركز الجناح حول
العالم ولم يحقق هدفه بالظهور بالمونديال
بسبب عدم تاهل منتخب بلاده عندما كان
باوجه عطائه وفي القائمه ايضا النجم
الفريدو دي ستفعلوا ورغمه تمثيله لمنتخبين
دوريين وهما الارجنتين واسبانيا الا انه
لم ينجح في الظهور في المونديال سواء مع
التانجو او او اخيرا مشاهدينا النجم
العربي المصري محمود الخطيب الملقب ببيبو
ورغم انجازاته الكبيره والكثيره الا انه
لم يحقق حلم اللاعب نهائيات كاس العالم مع
منتخب الفراعنه لعدم تاهل المنتخب عندما
كان الخطيب باوجه عطائه وبالرغم من تتويجه
مع نادي الاهلي باكثر من 15 بطوله محليه
وخمس بطولات افريقيه وبطوله الامم
الافريقيه عام 1986 مع المنتخب الوطني
وحصولها على الكره الذهبيه من فرانس
فوتبول الخاصه بافضل لاعب بافريقيا الا ان
الحظ لم يسانده في اللعب بالموت يعني
[موسيقى]
بين كل مفاجات كاس العالم تظهر مفارقه في
كواليس المباريات يبدو فيها رئيس ليبيريا
جو شويه وهو يهنئ ابنه اللاعب في منتخب
الولايات المتحده والذي يحمل الجنسيه بعد
ما احرز هدف الفوز للمنتخب
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
مع انتهاء مناورات امريكيه اسرائيليه
بايدن يدرس الخيار العسكري ضد ايران
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشف المبعوث الامريكي
الخاص بايران روبرت مالي ان الرئيس جو
بايدن مستعد لاستخدام الخيار العسكري بهدف
مانع ايران من حيازه سلاح النووي في حال
فاشله العقوبات والديبلوماسيه مضيفه انه
اذا لم تنجح العقوبات والضغط
والديبلوماسيه ستلجى اداره الرئيس
الامريكي الى استخدام القوه العسكريه ضد
طهران كملاذ اخير لمنع امتلاكها سلاح
النوويه واكد ما لان رئيس بايدن مازال
يعمل في ان تغير ايران مسارها الحالي
مشيرا الى ان المفاوضات غير مباشره بين
واشنطن وطهران توقفت بعد ما قدمت ايران
مطالب اضافيه لا علاقه لها لصلب الاتفاق
النووي وكرر مالي في الاونه الاخيره ان
واشنطن لم تعد ترى البرنامج النووي لايران
منفصلا عن القضايا الاخرى
[موسيقى]
انتهت اليوم التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه
بين القوات الجويه الاسرائيليه ونظيرتها
القوات الجويه الامريكيه والتي حاكى
الضربات بعيده المدى ضد المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه وفقا لصحيفه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ننتقل الى مؤتمر صحفي للرئيسين
الامريكي والفرنسي
في التعاون داخل الولايات المتحده بحيث
نعمل على تنسيق قطاعات الدفاعي والفضاء
والمجلات العلميه من اجل مراقبه المناخ
وقد اجرينا مناقشه مفصله حول تخفيض التضخم
وسوف ناخذه في صربي هذا الموضوع قال
الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي سوف يجريان استثمارات
كبيره في مجال الطاقه
العالميه في مجال سوف نعمل على تعزيز
مساله الاب همم
على ضفتي الاطلسي مع الولايات المتحده
وكذلك من خلال مشاوره مستمره رغم وجود بعض
الاختلافات بيننا حول هذه المساله
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا سوف يعملن على
تعزيز الصحه على المستوى العالمي
وتصادف زياره الرئيس المكرون في اليوم
العالمي للايدز نود هنا ان نعمل على تعزيز
الجهود من اجل انهاء مرض العز في العام
2030 وتحقيق كافه الاهداف المنشده ومن اجل
فعل ذلك لابد لنا من استثمار كافه الادوات
الموجوده بين ايدينا
لاستثاث هذا المرض ولهذا فاننا همم نشعر
بالفخر اللي همم ناخذ
المبادره من اجل العمل على راقد
ما قدمته فرنسا من رياده عالميه وهو كنا
قد قد قدمنا في صندوق العالمي لهذا الغرض
اكثر من 60 مليون دولار الامر الذي سوف
ينقذ حياه الناس في سوره العمل لو لي ان
ادرج كافه المجالات التعاون فيما بيننا
التي تحقق وتقدم فسوف نتحدث لفتره طويله
دعوني اختك مكالمه كلمتي بالحديث عن
الاستثمارات المشتركه التي سوف تعود
بالنفع على شعبين بيننا ونحن نحتفي
بالذكرى السنويه السابعه
الثانيه والسبعين في مجال التعاون العلمي
همم الامر الذي كان جوهريا وتجلى في العقد
الماضي بصوره محدده سوف تبقى تحالفتنا
قويه حتى الاجيال المقبله
انا اشكركم مجددا على كل ما تقوم به دولنا
معا في مجال التعاون وان اداره
وسياستنا الخارجيه تتماشى مع ما تقدمه
فرنسا وهذا التزام كبير من جانب لذا لانني
سعيد بلقائك صديقي واتطلع للعمل معك وهذا
اقل ما يمكن قوله
وانا كافه من هو هنا يرحب بك بحراره
شكرا السيد الرئيس
شكرا على هذه الكلمات اللطيفه التي تعكس
طبيعه النقاشات التي اجريناها لكن الاكثر
اهميه ان الاستقبال الذي
قضينا به يعكس
مدى الحراره
وعمق الصدقه التي تجمعنا
الوفد الذي رافقني في هذه الزياره
وفيما يخص الموضوع الطاقه
افتح ما الذي نقوم به سويه في اوكرانيا
فنحن سوريه من ندين هذه الحرب
التي شنتها روسيا فضلا عن جرائم الحرب
الذي التي تم اختراقها على اراضي اخرىنيه
واننا نقوم بدعم الجيش الاوكراني الذي
يعمل
عن الدفاع عن المواطنين
المتحده على كل هذا الدعم الذي قدمته لان
هذه الحرب تؤثر
بالموت طعمه
الاوروبي بصوره مباشره وقد قررتم ان
تستثمروا وان تسهموا في هذه الجهود
المشتركه وفي هذا السياق ان مناقشه تناها
هذا صباح كانت قد تطرقت الى مبادره سوف
يتم كشف النقاب عنها في الاسابيع القليله
المقبله للاستمرار في تعزيز دعمنا
للقوات الاوكرانيه
ومساعدتهم على الحاق الهزيمه في روسيا
وسوف نقدم الدعم للشعب الاخراني للصمود
بالانجليزي
من البناء المدنيه التحتيه
الامر الذي جعل الشعب الاوكراني بحاله من
الياس و يشعرون بمخوف كبيره من من فصل
الشتاء المقبل
واودوا في هذا السياق ان اشكركم على
التحضير على تحضير المؤتمر سوف يتم عقده
من اجل هذه مشاهدينا نكتفي بهذا القدر من
المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك للرئيسين الامريكي
والفرنسي سانتقل الان الى واشنطن وجونسون
لورد الباحث بمركز الامن الامريكي الجديد
استاذ جنى ثانيه يعني ما كنا نتحدث عنه
يتحدث عنه الرئيسان الان وهو منع طهران من
امتلاك سلاح نووي وتشديد الدولي على يعني
احباط هذا المشروع كيف يمكن منع طهران من
امتلاك سلاح نووي هل الخيار العسكري مطروح
وسط اولاويه الغرب اليوم اوروبا وامريكا
اولويه
في الشرق الاوسط
سبونج بوب
العسكري كان ولا يزال موجود على الطاوله
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده والعواصم
الغربيه وفي شهر يوليو عندما قام رئيس
بيدن بزياره اسرائيل فكان قد وقع على
اتفاقا المشترك
الذي كان يحمل عنوان اعلان القز الامر
الذي
اكد على انه لا يسمح لايران ان تمتلك
سلاحا نووي باي شكل من الاشكال وهذه
سياستنا وسوف يبقى الخير العسكري مطروحا
على الطاوله لتحقيق ذلك
هل الخيار العسكري يعني الجميع يستبعد ان
يكون خيار عسكري مفتوح وبالتالي نحن نتحدث
عن ضرب ربما اسرائيليه للمفاعلات النوويه
الايرانيه وهو مكان متحمس له نتنياه منذ
يعني ولايات الماضيه هل ممكن ان نشهد على
هكذا يعني ضربه محدوده كما فعلت اسرائيل
مرتين في السابق
باماكن اخرى طبعا
من خلال هذه
التمارين العسكريه التي همم تجري الانفاق
الولايات المتحده اسرائيل همم
عدم اظهار نواهي نواياه ما في ما يخصوا اي
ضربه عسكريه محتمله على ايران
التي تقودها اسرائيل واليوم الدول
الاوروبيه ضد النظام والثقه مع المتظاهرين
وغيره هل ممكن ان تعرقل الاتفاق النووي او
العمود الحديث عن الاتفاق النووي واذا لم
تعد يعني الولايات المتحده الى الاتفاق
النووي هل الضربه ستصبح لا محل ولا منها
عايزين
الضرب
منها فانا اتفاق خطه العمل الشامل المشترك
يبدو بعيدا المنال تذكره
الذي تحرك الشعب الايراني
وقبل ذلك كنا قد شاهدنا ما قدمته ايران من
صواريخ
ونندركم ما قدمته ايران من مطالب الاسره
لها في خطه العمل المشتركه الامر الذي
يصعب المساله برمتها وقد تصبح الامور اكثر
صعوبه للعوده
لكن اذا ما كانت الولايات المتحده للتدخل
في ايران فهذا سوف يتوقف على حيازه ايران
وهي تدرك بانها لزام عليها ان تعود دائما
لاتفاق النوويه
[موسيقى]
قلا دبلوماسيون في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
حكومات الدول الاعضاء اتفقت مبدايا اليوم
الخميس على حد اقصى لاسعار النفط الروسيه
المنقول بحرا قدره 60 دولارا للبرميل مع
اليه تعديل لابقاء سقف السعر اقل ب 5% من
سعر السوق وقال الدبلوماسيه بولندا هي
التي ضغطت من اجل خفض الحد الاقصى للاسعار
قدر الامكان ولكن يحتاج الاتفاق بعد ذلك
لموافقه مكتوبه من جميع حكومات دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى يوم الجمعه فيما
قالت الخارجيه الروسيه بان موسكو لن تزود
اي دوله توافق على وضعي سقف سعرا لنفطها
كشفت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وفشلها حتى
الان في اخضاعها ضعف الرئيس
وانهض صوته على جيرانه الاصغر خصوصا دول
اسيا الوسطى التي لا طالما اعتبرتها موسكو
جزء من ارث الاتحاد السوفيتي لعل ابرز
مؤشرات تراجع الصوت والروسيه تكونت في
موقف كازاخستان وطاجيكستان اللاتيني
عارضه علنا الغزو الروسي اوكرانيا رغم
ارتباطهما الوثيق بموسكو التي دعمت السلطه
في كازاخستان قبل اشهر ضد انتفاضه شعبيه
هدفها اسقاط النظام التحول في كازاخستان
هو الاهم فالقوه النفطيه المتراميه
الاطراف عمك علاقاتها مع الصين وتركيا
واوربا وجذبت مئات الشركات الغربيه التي
خرجت من روسيا كما سمحت للالاف من الروس
بالهرب من التجني عسكري بالعبور منها كما
تقول هنا الواشنطن بوست رئيس كازاخستان
قاسم جمعه الذي التقى بالرئيس الفرنسي في
باريس لمناقشه تعميق العلاقات الاقتصاديه
في رساله واضحه لموسكو عن بحث كازاخستان
عن بديل رحله الرئيس هنا جاءت عقب
اجتماعات الرئيس اوزباكستاني شوكت همم
ميروسيوف مع ماكرون في باريس الاسبوع
الماضي ارمينيا هي الاخرى بدات الخروج من
العباءه الروسيه حيث اعرضت عن غضبها من
نقص الدعم في الصراع العسكريه المستمر مع
اذربيجان
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من موسكو دي متر بريدج المحلل
السياسي استاذ مترو الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ
التسعينيات وهو يحاول الدخول الى دول اسيا
الوسطى ولكن استراتيجيته كانت تصطدم
يعني نفوذ موسكو بهذه المنطقه اليوم مع
تغير استراتيجيه هذه الدول والذهاب نحو
الانفتاح على اوروبا هل ممكن يعني ان ان
يكون هناك وجود اوروبي اقوى بموازات
الوجود الروسي او تضاعف الوجود الروسي
مساء الخير تحياتي لكم والاستاد المشاهدين
اعتقد بكل تاكيد الان دول السالوسطى لديها
سياسات مختلفه تجاه القضايا المختلفه
الدوليه ان كان حتى في الملف الاوكراني او
في ملفات اخرى من الواضح بان دول
اسيا الوسطى تحاول يتحرر من السياسات
الروسيه ونعرف بان في زمن الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق هذه الدول كانت تعتمد على
التحالف مع روسيا وبعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي تغيرت سياسات هو واصبحت اكثر
استقلاليه من التوجه السياسي الروسي او
توجه موسكو للسياسه الخارجيه من الواضح
بان الان كازاخستان وارمينيا وتجاكستان
وغيرها من الدول تحاول الان ايضا ان يعني
توجهها جديده في السياسه الخارجيه كون هي
مستفيده من علاقتها مع الدول الغربيه هذا
التوجه مع الدول الغربيه يعطي لها همم
يعني اهميه اقتصاديه ويعطي لها استثمارات
كازاخستان تعتمد جزئيه او كليا على
الاستثمارات الغربيه والاستثمارات
الاجنبيه ولذلك الان اين نرى بان الرئيس
همم كازاكي كاكايف يحاول الان في زيارته
الى فرنسا تقويه هذه العلاقات واعتقد بان
في روس الان بكل تاكيد راينا اللقاء
المشترك بين همم يعني دول اسيا الوسطى
الرئيس الروسي في نادي ليفربول وتنار بان
هناك خلافات ونزاعات بين قادت دول اسيا
الوسطى والرئيس الروسي الذي من بوتي في
كثير من الملفات لانه مثلا ارمينيا كانت
تعتمد على روسيا في حربها فينا جورج ولكن
الموقف الروسي كان ضعيف اذا الملف
وكان اقرب لي اذربيجان ولذلك لانه تغير
التوجه هارمينيا وايضا كازاخستان في عهد
توقيف همم يعني تغير التوجهها نعرف ان في
عهد الرئيس السابق انا اقرب التوجه
السياسي اقرب من روسيا ولكن الان بعد دعم
رؤوس التكيف تغير التوجه في كذا فستان نحو
يعني توجه
مختلفات الاقتصاديه يعني تدفع هذه الدول
نحو الذهاب الى خيارات اخرى ايضا ولكن
هناك البعض يعتبر بان المحاولات ما زالت
هشه
عندما يعني بعد الانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان وخطر طلبان وخطر الجماعات
الارهابيه بظل يعني الموقع الاستراتيجي
لافغانستان هناك خصوصا ان موسكو ما زالت
لاعب اساسي بهذه المنطقه هل ممكن يعني هذا
الخوف من هذه النقطه تحديدا ان يحد من
الانفلات لهذه الدول عن موسكو
بكل تاكيد الان روسيا حتى الان لها هيمنه
عسكريه ولها ايمانه ان كان اقتصاديه
وتعاون مع هذه الدول دول اسيا الوسطى
ولذلك هذه الدول لن تستطيع ان تذهب بعيدا
في تعاونها مع الدول الغربيه لانه هي تفهم
وتدرك تداعيات ذلك يتفهم بان ذهاب
وتعاونها مع الدول الغربيه قد تسبب لها
مشاكل همم مع روسيا وهي لا تريد خساره
روسك شريك اقتصادي وكشريك مهم في المنطقه
ولذلك هي تفهم بانها لن تستطيع الذهاب
بعيدا في تعاونها مع الدول الغربيه من جهه
ولكن بجاه اخرى يجب ان نفهم بان الان
السياسه الخارجيه الروسيه مختلفه تماما عن
سياسه هذه الدول وهذه الدول لها يعني توجه
مختلفه لها اراء مختلفه ايذاء الملفات
الان الموجوده في الساحه السياسيه ولذلك
يتحاول يكون لها راي مختلف وهي تحاول ان
يعني ان تكون اقرب للدول الغربيه وتتعاون
مع الدول العربيه تستفيد من ذلك كما الصين
همم شكرا نعم شكرا لك استاذ ديميتري بريشي
المحلل السياسي حدثنا من موسكو
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
شرائح المخ ستدخل مرحله التجارب على البشر
في غضون اشهر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد صفقه محتمله قد ترسم
ملامح العلاقه المستقبليه بين النظام
السوري وتركيا محورها شمال شرق سوريا
وضحياتها قصد الرافده لاي اتفاق بعد ما
خذلتها الولايات المتحده يقول موقع مدن ان
الخطه غير المعلنه يبدو انها ترتكز على
اعاده الاعتبار لنظام الاسد كدوله وهذا
يعني ازاله كل الكيانات التي تعترض طريق
اعاده تلك الصفه اليه فانقرا قد تقدم على
كل على حل للفصائل العسكريه المعروفه او
تقدم على حل الفصائل العسكريه المعروفه
باسم الجيش الوطني او تسليمها للروس
لدمجها لجيش النظام مع وضع ترتيبات خاصه
بهيئه تحرير الشام بعد انجاز المهمه شرق
الفرات وشمال سوريا اولا ويريد الاتراك
انتشارا حقيقيا لقوات النظام على الحدود
معها ودافع عن قوه الكرديه بعيدا او حلها
على ان تتسلم قوات الاسد المعابر الحدوديه
على الاقل في مناطق انتشار الجيش الوطني
وسيكون هذا اكثر من كافا للنظام اذا ما
ساعدته الضغوط التركيه على دفع القوات
الامريكيه للانسحاب من شرقي البلاد واعاده
مناطق الشمال والشرق الى نفوذتهم اما
بالنسبه لاردوغان فهناك قضايا تشغل بالك
فل نتابعها
[موسيقى]
لكن مشاهدينا طبعا كل هذا السيناريو مبنيه
على فرضيه ابتدائيه وهي استسلام القوات
الكرديه لنظام الاسد وهو امر لم يحدث بعد
ورفضته قصد كما تقول الشرق الاوسط اما
البديل عن هذه المقترحات فسيكون عمليه
بريه خاطئه لكنها لن تكون سهله عموما وقد
تصنع واقعا مغيرا تقول المدن طبعا وضع
الاكراد او وضع الاكراد كاضحيه لسياسات
الولايات المتحده والغرب ليس جديد عليهم
انما الشديد هذه المره ان قصه ساهمت
بوصلهم الى هذه الحال من ضمن اطراف اخرى
فتاريخيا تعرض الاكراد خلال 100 عام لسبعه
خيانات من الحليفه المفترضه والداعمه
الولايات المتحده ففي مقال لها ايضا في
الشرق الاوسط تقول انها لن تكون المره
الاولى وربما ليست المره الاخيره التي قد
يتعرض فيها الاكراد لخيانه امريكيه او
غربيه في حال لم يكن الرد على تواغل تركي
ضد اهداف كرديه في سوريا في مستوى
توقعاتهم ولعل اول هذه الخيانات الامريكيه
للاكراد كانت بعد انهيار الامبراطوريه
العثمانيه في الحرب العالميه الاولى حين
خصصت معاهده معاهده معاهده العام 1920
مساحه للاكراد في تركيا كي يقيموا حكما
ذاتيا ثم تراجعت الولايات المتحده عنها في
معاهدات عام
1963 قامت الولايات المتحده بدعم اكراد
العراق ضد النظام عبد العال كريم قاسم عام
1963 ثم تخلت عن دعمهم بمباركه من اداره
الرئيس الامريكي الجديد انا ذاك جلد
ثمانينيات وتسعينيات اداره الرئيس رونالد
ريجان التزمت الصمت على استعمال بغداد
اسلحه كيماويه في كردستان العراق وفي عام
2003 بعد الغزو الامريكي للعراق لم يحصل
الاكراد على تاييد امريكيه يدعم انفصالهم
عن العراق وفي عام 2017 اراد الزعيم
الكردي مسعود البرزاني تنظيم استفتاء
لتقرير المصير فعرضت هنا الولايات المتحده
واعلن التحفظها على هذه الخطوه وفي سوريا
تعرض الاكراد لاكثر من طعنا او من امريكا
بعد ما قتلوا له سنوات ضد تنظيم داعش لكن
هم لم يحصلوا على الدعم السياسي لا بل
تلقوا صدمه لعدم اعتراضيهم على ثلاث
عمليات عسكريه تركيه ضد مناطق الاكلات
شمال سوريا بين عام 2016
2018 و2019
[موسيقى]
معنى من اسطنبول المحلل السياسي الدكتور
سمير صالحه دكتور سمير سمير يعني ما سمعته
بكل ما عرضناه الان هل يمكن ان يكون الحل
مشددا عن طريق يعني بيع الاكراد على طاوله
التفاوض بين القوات الدوليه
ايه مساء الخير للجميع اولا يعني طبعا
المسؤوليه الاساسيه هي برايه هنا مسؤوليات
واشنطن لماذا لانه بنت حساباتها على هذه
المجموعات
واستخدمتها في موضوع ربما داعش في اطار
وعود قدمت لهذه المجموعات والان يبدو انه
واشنطن تجد مشكله في همم تنفيذ تعهداتها
التي قدمتها لماذا لانه خارطه
التحالفات في سوريا كما تتابعين انت ايضا
تتغير باستمرار
وريهان واشنطن على هذه المجموعات لم يعد
كافيا في المرحله المقبله لاعطائها ما
تريد بضمانات امريكيه ثم تدخل واشنطن في
في النزاع بشكل مباشر بشكل عسكري السياسي
الميداني واما ان تعلن انها فعلا غير
قادره على همم تن هذه
التعهدات وهذا برئي شق الثاني هو الاقرب
نعم دكتور سمير يعني بالفتره الماضيه صر
بالكثير من البنود عن الاتفاقيه المحتمله
بين الجانب السوري اي النظام والجانم
التركي ولكن كل البنود تقريبا يعني ما
المطلوب من انقره اكثر بكثير من المطلوب
من النظام هل ممكن ان تكون هناك علاقات
يعني مصالحه شامله ام انها همم يعني
مصالحه اردوغانيه انت غبيه
همم الخطه التركيه منذ البدايه برايه كانت
تقوم على طاوله حوار ثلاثي همم بشكل او
بياخر يجمع الرؤوس الامريكان والتراك
لباحث هذا الملف ليس فقط في موضوع المناطق
الحدوديه بدات في التعامل في الحوار حول
الملف السوري السياسي لكن حتى الان يبدو
انه ما في لا يوجد اختراقات حقيقيه لبناء
هذه الطاوله الثلاثيه نقطه ثانيه الخطه
الامريكيه غير موجوده طالما قلنا قبل قليل
انه تلعب ورقه وقصد ولا يوجد اي تفاهمات
لها لا مع الجانب التركي او من جانب
الروسي او معاني النظام او غير ذلك اذا
تبقى كماشرتها انت ايضا بوادر او ملامح
الخطه الروسيه لكن هذه الخطه ايضا فيها
الكثير من التشابه والتدخل لن تكون سهله
اطلاقا العقبه الاساسيه فيها هي كذا لانه
قصد ما زال تراين على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيها وتتمسك بان واشنطن لا كلا انا
لذلك هي لا تريد ان تطمئن روسيا في مسائل
حساسه بينها فتحه الطريق امام دخول قوات
النظام الى المناطق الحدوديه نعم شكرا لك
يا دكتور سمير صالحه حدثتنا من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
اصدر القضاء التونسي المذكرات ضبط واحضار
بحق شخصين موجودين خارج البلاد احدهما نجل
رئيس حركه النهضه معاذ الغنوشي في قضيه
تكوين مجموعه من اجل تغيير شكل الدوله
والاعتداء على الامن الداخلي واثاره
الفوضى بين السكان
معنى من تونس مشاهدينا مراسل العربيه وليد
عبد الله وليد يعني تفاصيل ما ورد بهذا
الخبر معك تفضل
مساء الخير تفاصيل الخبر تؤكد ان وكيل
الجمهوريه نطق الرسمي باسم المحكمه
الابتدائيه في محافظه القصرين الحدوديه مع
الجزائر اعلن واكد ان السلطات القضائيه
التونسيه
اصدرت بطاقه جلبن وتفتيش في حق نجل راشد
الغنوشي معاذ الغنوشي بتهمه تكوين وفاق من
اجل الاعتداء على امن الدوله
الداخلي وتبديل هيئه الدوله وحمل السكان
على مهاجمته بعضهم البعض واثاره الهرج
والبلبله هذه هي التهمه الموجهه لراس
الدولي راشد الغنوشي معاذ الغنوشي لماذا
بطاقه الجلب لسبب بسيط لان معاذ الغنوشي
هو الان خارج حدود الوطن وبالتالي من بارد
جدا ان السلطات التونسيه قد تكون وجهه
مذكره الى الشرطه الجنائيه الدوليه
الانتربول لجلب معاذ الغنوشي للتحقيق معه
في تونس على اعتبار انه غادر البلاد قبل
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه في الخامس والعشرين
من يوليو يتنقل وفق مصادقنا بين انجلترا
التي يحمل جنسيتها وسويسرا
والتركيا وتعود اصول القضيه الى نهايه
الشهر شهر 10 تحديدا يوم العشرين منه
حينما فتحت انياب العموميه بحثا تحقيقها
ضد اربعه اشخاص بتهمه تلقي اموال وتوزيعها
لاثاره البلبله في محافظه القصرين على
خلفيه الاحتجاجات حول عدم توفر المواد
الاستهلاكيه وان من بين هذه المجموعه نجوى
رئيس برلمان سابق وايضا رئيس حزب سياسي
سابقا
معاذ الغنوش اذا الشبه تتحول الى التهمه
ويبدو انك تحقيقه على كل حال عبد الله
سنبقى نتابع معك يعني وليد عفوا سنبقى
نتابع معك تفاصيل هذه القضيه وما سينتج
عنها بالايام والساعات المقبله شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
شرائح المخ ستدخل مرحله التجارب على البشر
في غضون اشهر قليل هذا اعلان زفه
الملياردير الى ماسك الذي اكد ان التجارب
على البشر ستتم باستخدام اداه لاسلكيه
طورتها شركته
المتخصصه في صنع شرائح المخ وان ذلك قد
يتم خلال سته اشهر مضيفا ان احد اوائل
التطبيقات المستهدفه من خلال هذه التجارب
السريريه على البشر هو واستعاده البصر
وانتحه الحركه لعضلات اشخاص عاجزين وتقوم
الشركه بتطوير وصلات شريحه للمخ تقول انها
قد تمنح المرضى المصابين باعاقات القدره
على الحركه والتواصل من جديد
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نعود الى احتفالات المنتخب
المغربي الطريق
[تصفيق]
النهائي هذا بالفرنسي حكم النهائي نشوف
شباب كثير مثل ما وصلوا من مناطق مختلفه
ودائما التشجيع انت كان عندك حكي كثير هذا
الفوز اول شيء بنهديه حق العرب كله كل
العرب واحد وان شاء الله رفعوا راسنا
الرجال وحبيت اشكر اللعيبه اللي كانوا
وايد وايد والله وايد رجاله وان شاء الله
الفوز في المباراه الجايه يا اسبانيا
اليابان
[موسيقى]
اخذنا الصوره عمق الصوره ليال بنشوف كذلك
انه يوجد الكثير من الحسود يوجد الحدود
الملعب
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله المنتخب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في النشرات اللاحقه ومع الزملاء لنقل فرحه
المنتخب المغربي همم ساترك الان شكرا لك
ليث بازاري ليس هل ممكن ان ناخذ بعض من
ردود الفعل من يعني الذين وصلوا الان واا
يسيرون معك الى السوق
نعم يوجد يوجد الكثير يعني هون تفضلوا
شباب من وين انتم من المغرب الدار البيضاء
المغرب المنتخب المغربي
كده نعطي صوره للمشاهد العربي عبر العربيه
عن الاحتفالات راح تصير بسوق واقف كيف راح
تكون
مبهره مبهره خطيره تعالوا معنا وتشوفوا
هذه يعني يا ليال كمان نشاهد يعني الجميع
اتجاه من مشيره بهذه المنطقه جنوبا الى
سوق واقف وبعد ذلك
مشاهدينا مع هذه الفرحه المغربيه تنتهي
التاسعه ولكن اخبار العربيه مستمره وايضا
نقل فرحه المنتخب المغربي والعالم سنكملها
بالنشرات اللاحقه اليكم
الموضوع والف الف مبروك
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]